Il y a tout le monde
Il y a déjà une belle team
Là, on n'est pas au complet
J'ai quelque chose de gros
Elle est entière
Elle est toute neuve
Pour quand vous partez en camping les gars
Parfait !
Tu as vu comme on te reçoit ? On te met les chaises dans l'eau
Merci
Allé !
Ah, Rasta
Il aime l'eau le chien ?
Il n'aime pas trop, non
Du barbelé, du barbelé de la guerre !
Ca ressemble
C'est ça
Sympa
C'est un barbelé de la guerre
Super, on a pas ça chez nous
Quand tu as deux ou trois branches, c'est un barbelé de la guerre
J'ai un truc ! J'ai quelque chose
Oh non, c'est de la vase
Tu veux de la vase ?
Tiens
Allé la caisse
La caisse enregistreuse
Non ! Dommage
Il va la retrouver
Il l'a accroché comme une buse, je ne suis pas étonné
Attention, surveillez Quentin, en général il vole les pièces à l'intérieur
Voilà !
Ce n'est pas très lourd
Il y a la clef. C'est un bonne nouvelle
1 centime d'euro
Elle n'est pas vide
Un peu rouillé
Elle est bien vide
Résultat, 1 centime d'euro dedans
Le vélo avec son anti vole bidon
Ah, pardon
Désolé
Rasta, on a besoin de toi
Il ne faut pas que ça casse
C'est bon ! Ca a bougé
Regardez moi ça ! Regardez l'équipe
Allé les gars du Sud
Ah oui, il était vraiment dans la vase
Il a été gentil, il en a mi qu'une
Vous n'avez pas l'habitude de ça !
Ah non, pas d'aussi haut
Bravo
Vous avez bien fait de venir du Sud
Bien joué les gars, bravo
Belle trouvaille
Faut arriver à identifier la marque
Dites le nous en commentaire
Les professionnels des motos, on sait que vous êtes là
Il a ouvert la boîte à outils de la moto, il y a tous les outils dedans
Sympa
Tu as géré gamin
Il y ne a peut être certain de restaurables
Il va venir sur ma corde mais il part dans l'autre sens
C'est à cause du courant
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est ça Quentin ?
Un morceau de la moto je pense, sur le côté
Avec un tube
Peut être
Cadeau
Merci
Cadeau empoisonné
C'est vrai que les float tubes sont efficaces quand c'est loin
Celles avec le rond sont mes préférées
Marquages "35-4"
A l'époque c'était du calibre 7.65, il n'y avait pas beaucoup de 9mm
Oui tu as raison, ça doit venir d'un pistolet Français
C'est du calibre 7.65
Belle trouvaille, bien joué
Quentin, Baptiste le numéro 1 de l'association, il est là
Ah ! Le chef
Non, il est là le chef !
Le deuxième chef
C'est la première recrue
J'ai quelque chose
Quentin il est chaud
Bien sûr
Un pot, pour compléter celui qu'on vous a apporté
Comme c'est bizarre, on a l'habitude d'en faire ici
Ah, il y a des professionnels des catalyseurs
Il est plein de vase, personne n'est en dessous ?
On voit que le courant peut être violent
La caisse enregistreuse, ils l'ont trouvé à au moins 30 mètres
Regardes, ils sont tous rempli, chaise, vélo, caisse enregistreuse
Bon spot ici
C'est quoi ça ?
On dirait une brique en métal
Il y a du cuivre
Le ferrailleur va être content
Je n'ai pas filmé le lancé mais j'ai trouvé un joli Franc
1 franc de 1975
JP, tu es née en quelle année ?
Si tu veux mon âge, j'ai 18 ans
Ah c'est 1975, ce n'est pas pour toi alors
A mon avis c'est de la fonte les gars
Un morceau de radiateur
Il est lourd celui là !
C'est bon, tu as réussi ton baptême
Le baptême du radiateur
Ah, vous n'avez pas l'habitude
Ils ne jettent pas des radiateurs chez nous dans le Sud
On a pas de radiateurs dans le Sud
On en sait même pas ce que c'est, j'en avait jamais vu
On a enfin compris d'où venaient les chargeurs
Ouais, il est fatigué celui là
Belle trouvaille
Alors le plongeur de la team !
On nous conseil d'investir dans des float tubes, c'est vrai que ça marche pas mal
Oui ca aide pas mal
Encore un morceau de pot d'échappement, un catalyseur
Merci
Un couteau à beurre
Non, à fromage
Ah oui, c'est ce que je voulais dire
C'est du plastique, pas de la corne
Ca reste sympa, belle trouvaille
Il a l'air bien aiguisé pour couper du fromage
C'est étrange
T'es virée !
C'est pour ça que vous nous dites qu'il faut acheter des float tubes
Pour la sieste
C'est une mobylette apparemment
Il ne faut jamais se fier à ce qu'ils annoncent
Ils ont vu que le pot d'échappement je crois pour l'instant
Ca ne vient pas du tout, on va essayer de jeter un grappin avec
Pourtant on est nombreux à tirer
Baptiste, il faut le palan 6 tonnes peut être
Ben, tu vas le chercher toi
Allé, le cadre de moto
Allez y les gars
Alors les petits gars du Sud ? Sympa la Sartres ?
Belles trouvailles ouais
Pas besoin de frotter, on voit ce que c'est
Peugeot 103 Kit, il y a une pédale
Il y a Christopher qui va tenter de faire faire du float tube à Rasta
Il n'en a jamais fait, il a déjà fait du bateau
Viens
Assis, Rasta
C'est bien Rasta
Je l'ai filmé
Il n'a pas peur
Il est habitué, il n'a peur de rien
Pauvre chien
Il va vomir, arrêtez
Après on doit l'amener en voiture
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font à notre mascotte chez Peche Aveugl'Aimant
C'est du jamais vu, de l'exclusivité totale
Rasta sur un float tube
Il n'en avait jamais fait je crois ?
C'est son baptème
Si tu ne sais pas quoi lui acheter à Noël
Allé Rasta, tu descends ?
Tendez, tendez
Palan 6 tonnes bonjour !
JP a sorti le palan
Je crois que la fin de journée à commencée
Ouais, dernière trouvaille
Il est écrasé
Bravo les gars ! Bien joué
C'est le dernier de la journée, au moins il est sorti
Oh ! Un mollusque
Ce n'est pas des vacances
C'est la fin de cette session avec toute la team Peche Aveugl'Aimant
Bien sûr, vous aurez tous leurs réseaux en description
Regardez comme ils sont musclés, ils sont tous comme ça
Allé, à la ferraille !
A la poubelle
On est maintenant au Mans
Devant le quartier général de la 7ème armée allemande
Regardez la belle voiture devant le musée
Nous voilà devant le Bunker AOK7
JP nous a dit qu'il y a pas mal de surprises à l'intérieur, on a hâte de rentrer
Regardez comme il est massif
Ce n'est que ce qui dépasse, le reste est sous terre
Là tu avais les appartements du général Dollmann
Un général d'Hitler
Il gérait l'occupation de toute cette partie de la France
Ainsi que de la protection du mur de l'Atlantique
Regardez, ils ont déjà de belles pièces même à l'extérieur
Celui là n'a pas été pêché
Il était dans un poulailler ils nous ont dit
Allé, c'est parti
Pêche interdite
C'est toi qui a fait mettre ça ?
Je te promet que ce n'est pas moi
C'est une dédicace à JP
Ca c'est à nous
Des chargeurs d'MG40
Ils sont bien conservés
Ils sont soudés à la boîte ?
Non, non, ils sortent
Donc pêchés par l'association
Tout est d'époque sauf l'arme qui est une fausse
Le couteau est d'époque
Ah oui il est sympa
Lance fusées LP42
Celui-là on l'a déjà démonté et restauré
On a même tiré avec
Tous les objets ici ont été trouvés dans le département de la Sarthe
On travaille en collaboration avec l'association des Pêcheurs à l'aimant sur toutes les pièces qui peuvent être sorties de l'eau
Et qui sont en lien avec la seconde guerre mondiale
Là vous êtes dans le bunker de commandement
Vous avez ici le PC de commandement dans son état d'origine
Il a été fermé en 1946
Nous sommes entré à l'intérieur en 2011
Vous avez tout le système électrique, la ventilation, le chauffage, le lavabo
Quand il a été fermé, rien n'a été pillé
Le but de l'association c'est de l'avoir restauré
Et remis en fonction d'origine
En fait ici tout est fonctionnel
Tout le système de communication a été testé
Avec l'ensemble des prises électriques et téléphoniques
ça fonctionne
Ah ouais incroyable !
Et on a un nouveau projet sur 8000 mètres carrés de terrain
On refait le camp de prisonniers
Le plus grand camp de prisonniers de l'ouest
ça ça s'appelle un conteneur de parachutage
c'était envoyé par avion par les anglais pour fournir la résistance
D'accord
Donc à l'intérieur c'est remplis d'armes
Ouais
Il faut en pêcher un entier à l'aimant
Ah là ce serait le vrai cadeau de noël
On va ajouter toutes les informations en description avec l'adresse du lieu aussi
ça vous allez me dire que c'est une passoire
Mais avant c'était pas une passoire mais un casque de parachutiste allemand
Parce que après la seconde guerre mondiale les allemands n'avaient plus de ferraille
Ouais ouais
Donc ils ont récupéré tous les objets militaires dont les casques
Et ils ont crées des machines pour repoinçonner
Et faire des ustensiles
Je ne savais pas ça
Mais c'est vrai qu'il y en avait tellement...
Tu avais des piles entières de casques
ça c'est la sirène d'alerte
Que j'ai trouvé dans la poubelle du collège
Dans la poubelle ?
ici au dessus il y a un collège
Et donc elle venait d'ici ?
oui, et ça partait à la poubelle
la porte pèse 660kg
Celle là si vous la sortez avec un aimant, ça va vous faire mal aux fesses
Très beau musée
Bravo
Vous avez visité avec nous une partie du bunker
Mais il reste beaucoup de choses à découvrir, ainsi que des projets d'agrandissement
N'hésitez pas à vous y rendre et vous serrez bien reçus pas l'association AOK7
Encore un grand merci à l'équipe de Pêche Aveugl'aimant et à JP son président
Toutes les infos sur Pêche Aveugl'aimant et le Bunker sont en description, à la semaine prochaine !